where's my camera you try a lot of
cameras it's an exciting day first all
women's spacewalk underway right now
they're doing very important work I just
so everybody knows where this is a short
window for the downlink and also they've
got very busy work to do they're on the
outside of the station but what a big
day we're thrilled to be here mr.
president it's over to you for
communicating with them well I'm
thrilled also and if they're ready I'm
ready
okay can we confirm that the link is
live station this is President Donald
Trump do you hear me that's great I was
starting to get worried about you you're
an interesting place
I thought we may have to be a little
emergency work I don't think that'll
ever be necessary with you the job that
you do is incredible and I'm here with
Vice President Mike Pence
NASA Administrator Jim bridenstine and
my daughter Ivanka we're thrilled to be
speaking live with two brave American
astronauts who are making history
joining us during their spacewalk
outside the International Space Station
and this is the first time for a woman
outside of the space station
our flight engineers Christina cook and
flight engineer Jessica Muir and I just
want to congratulate you what you do is
incredible it's oh you're very brave
people I don't think I want to do it I
must tell you that but you are amazing
people there conducting the first-ever
female spacewalk to replace an exterior
part of the space station they're doing
some work and they're doing it in a
very high altitude and altitude that
very few people will ever see
congratulations Christina and Jessica on
this historic event this is truly
historic and you're right now on
television all over the world so don't
get nervous I'd like to ask you a
question what would you like to tell
everyone listening and watching today
especially young women who are
interested in space we don't want to
take too much trouble because there have
been many other female speakers before
this is the first time that there's been
two women outside at the same time and
it's really interesting for all we've
talked a lot about it up here you know
for us this is really just us doing our
job it's something we've been training
for for six years and preparing for and
so things really you know it's just
coming out here and doing our jobs and
he was a we were the crew that was happy
for this assignment the same time we
recognize that it is an afterlife
achievement and we do of course want to
give credit to all those that came
before there's been a long line of
female scientists explorers engineers
and astronauts we have all in their
footsteps to get us where we are today
inspiration everybody not only women but
to everybody that has a dream that has a
big dream and they're willing to work
hard to make that dream come true
something that all of us that have made
a way out here have gone out all my life
and I can tell you that I work certainly
didn't pay off only been up here a few
weeks actually about three weeks
pressing in
my first and my very first space walk it
is a pretty incredible feeling I'm sure
you can all imagine and it's one that
I'll never forget I'm extremely
fortunate to be sharing this moment with
Christina cook those are only my
colleagues but also a very very close
and dear friend so it's really our honor
to be out here working today if they're
representing whatever it is the
significance or whatever whatever
individuals devices and heart thank you
well Christina and Jessica I would like
to if I could just thank you Jessica I
know that you've been doing this and
you've been working hard and Christine
I've studied your resume it's really
incredible what you've done what you've
both done your lives have been
incredible and now you're in a place
that as I said very few people will ever
get that experience you're doing an
incredible job this is a first step
because we're going to the moon and then
we're going to Mars we're launching from
the moon most likely they seem to think
that's the best way of doing it Jim so
we're launching from the moon and I just
want to congratulate you both you're
very brave brilliant women and you
represent this country so well and our
country is very proud of you and we are
very proud of you millions and millions
of people are watching you right now but
I will tell you what you do is is really
something very special so first the moon
and then we go to Mars thank you both
very much have a good time
wondering if we might have lost the link
maybe they didn't like my message anyway
two great women two great people and
they danger not easy it's not an easy
thing to do a lot of people would take a
pass on that one but they're great women
oh I think I heard that that's the link
that's the end of the link so they heard
my message and they tried to respond I
assume they're okay I assume they're
okay anyway they're actually outside of
the ship so that's something right
that's the first time there since 1969
that a president has spoken to
astronauts outside of the space ships
and that was a great that was a great
it's a great thing when are they coming
back what's the time so each one is
different
Cristina cook is actually going to be
the longest so she's gonna be on Space
Station for I think it's about ten
months what's the longest for a Maronite
345 days so why don't you have the woman
break the record well we have a very
tight schedule when it comes to windows
to get back and forth to the
International Space Station but that's
within the realm of what is possible we
were working on schedules that's right
my direction of the president we will
have the the first man or I should say
the first woman and next man on the
South Pole of the moon will be American
and what's your timing
get it and get it done before you talk
about 2024 sir we if all things go
according to plan 2024 is in the within
the realm of what is possible and we're
working hard to make that a real and
because of the fact that we've been
there as I've said to you many times
we've been there long time ago it's
really being done as a as a launch for
Mars is that correct that's right we're
building a habitat in orbit around the
moon a space station in orbit around the
moon and that we'll be launching in 2022
and once that is deployed that will be
modified into a Mars ship that will take
this all the way to Mars
and between now and then we want to
build a sustainable architecture at the
moon we need to learn how to live and
work on another world for long periods
of time and then we go to Mars because
when you go to Mars Earth and Mars we're
only aligned on the same side of the Sun
once every once every 24 months or 26
months what that means is we have to be
willing to stay right we need to learn
how to live and work on another way so
yeah right that's what the moon is all
about it's gonna be very interesting
what's very exciting exciting times and
that whole program was dead when I took
it over when we came into office and
something that Mike liked very much and
I liked very much and you're both doing
a fantastic job and everybody's doing a
fantastic job it's been totally
reinvigorated I think to a level that
has never been aired and we're also
thinking in terms of defense we have the
space force happening that's going along
very nicely as you know we're creating a
new force and it's called a space force
and that's a big thing and that'll be
working along very closely with you so
that's beyond going to the Moon and Mars
that's also a defense of our nation
that's right is very important anywhere
there's commerce it needs to be defended
and we are industrializing space it's
going to be an export for the United
States and that's going to be very
positive in fact it already is we need
to grow it and so we're working very
hard to commercialize it making an
export and of course that requires it to
be defended just like the high seas for
for trade and it's fantastic thank you
very much great job thank you well thank
you very much everybody that was very
exciting and these are two great people
and they put themselves at risk for our
nation and because they love doing it
and there are a few people that have the
ability to do something like that I will
say that it takes a great ability so
thank you all for being here it's very
nice thank you